but my point as far as what this program
is I would only do something if I
thought it set a precedent where
students would feel more capable in
expressing themselves where students
wouldn't have to live in fear for our
very first defense should be
institutions that at the very least
apply their own policies fairly when
people are clearly in the wrong like
professors exactly so listen we're
really glad to have half-asian what my
half-asian will are bill Richman in in
studio here today and third chair
Crowder confronts went up a lot of plays
a lot of people talking about it a lot
of people are saying that we need to sue
for libel or slander which is not really
what yeah here we have to pick our legal
battles I wouldn't know what your
opinion is when you watch the video and
when enough is enough for what you think
should be done before we talk about the
legality with my half-asian lawyer bill
Richman bill what do you what are you
thinking a lot of people are saying you
should sue this teacher or this school
which you know we never set out to do we
tried to reach out to their lawyers we
registered so that we were sent to the
cops to see now had been a report filed
for all the death threats it wasn't and
nothing was done what do you think in
this case what's what's the right thing
to do you know you become very concerned
about if something isn't done that it
continues to happen what if it's someone
who doesn't have a platform to be able
to fight back or something that has an
audience and you worry about what are
the impact on certain students and they
feel that they see someone in power at
this university is getting away with
telling blatant lies you know accusing
people of crimes and what do they learn
about the system what is crying by the
way threatening to kill someone's son
and also calling for genocide in at
least 48 states okay all right I mean in
so the idea that we that either the
university wouldn't step in to do
something and sure they've got other
considerations you know what not but but
when you get to something that's so very
clearly over the line it comes a matter
of not just the university not just the
students but perhaps even the parents
and I think we've seen some backlash
from folks in the community who say why
would I want to send my students or send
my son or daughter to a place that's
allowing this kind of defamation this
kind of accusations you shouldn't don't
go as low as the left listen we haven't
we haven't slandered the guy no we
haven't committed a libel we've never
said that it would never made any false
claims that he's a Nazi or that he's I
don't know actually I don't know what
maybe he could be coming so we've never
made the claim that no possible
I've never made any false direct claims
that he's committed and we wouldn't want
to do that here's the truth people say
nothing will change until you sue
because this guy will go on as usual I
don't know if that's true you know
having the biggest conservative YouTube
channel out there is a platform and it's
we've been blessed with it and it also
affords us the ability to shine a light
on this and we also don't want to be
fighting every single time they can hear
we could be focusing on content so there
is a there is a give and take a bill to
go back to you first of what there was
libel and slander for people who don't
know in this case it was both so we
talked about this in a barely legal but
the libel part is going to be the
written part and slander is gonna be
anything that's done verbally so both of
those fall under the calendar the the
umbrella of defamation but it's the way
in which it's conveyed so newspaper
versus speaking it or you're doing it at
a rally or some type of thing like that
and those are the old in terms that have
carried forward today particularly in
certain states well okay so in this case
obviously I would imagine that this
lecturer professor doesn't have a whole
whole lot right so as far as write with
slander with libel you were talking
about damages so it can be there there
are certain types of defamation that
require damages there are certain types
of defamation that do not they can
they're defamation per se or certain
types of defamation that would only have
nominal damages and so the house like I
need that was a legal term and he's a
definition per se it wasn't like a
basketball kinds of like defamation per
se lawyer whoever's doing the closed
captioning just put those in italics
tell you that it's lat yeah there's
different ways to approach in defamation
laws is an important area changes in
every state it changes even decade to
decade and year to year because of some
of the cases that come out but some of
the things that become very clearly part
of the problem and get very far over the
line or when you're accusing someone of
a crime multiple times you know that
it's not the case and that's what's
something that would very clearly rise
to the level of malicious you're doing
it because you know it's going to hurt
that person's reputation to accuse them
of that particular crime even though you
know it's false right well in the whole
beginning of this was trying to get you
not to be able to express your opinions
on the campus at a that is how this
begins trying to sublease each saying
that I said you know to get I call
for the gassing of all the Jews right at
all of these faces though all of these
falsehoods that was the initial reason
was to silence free speech so I do you
know my perspective and this is what I
want to hear from people in the comments
section you know we have so many legal
battles that we could pick on a daily
basis and we usually don't because even
a good example of D monetization or
restrictions we talk with YouTube but we
generally try to focus on content we
generally try to move on down the trail
and say okay let's adapt we've created
mud club thank you for people who
support it that's why we're here we
wouldn't do it through YouTube alone for
me it really is about the people if I
weren't me and I don't say that the
sound arrogant but if this weren't the
louder with crowd or show yeah I never
work again
yeah right so he runs a search to to
hire me and says oh you called for the
gassing of just you threatened to kill a
man son well I know I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna take this right what concerns
me is is other people out there who
don't have a platform so I understand a
lot of them feel a lot of college
students think that if there isn't some
kind of a lawsuit nothing changes for
them absolutely they're the ones who
were sitting there raised their hand to
given a a counter opinion to a professor
who's clearly has a favor on the far
left spectrum of the students exactly
and so you know what does the university
say when they say we absolutely
appreciate this person who gets up and
tells blatant lies accusing people of
crimes right absolutely did not commit
right they're saying you student just
keep your hand down you soon just close
your mouth right open your book and go
home and don't say a word
yeah at the very least some a suit like
this would shine a light on this
situation and say hey if you're gonna do
stuff like this there are people out
here that will sue you and make sure
that comes up that's illegal as a whole
by the way there is there are some other
what's the email we have set up as a tip
line at Lauder with credit com
send your this is what you can do run
your phone okay yeah video if you see
professor doing this do that especially
if you're in a single party consent
state know the law yeah but in Texas you
are not if you're not I think there are
11 states that are that are dual party
consent States at least shine a light on
it some people say someone is the best
disinfectant alcohol probably more
effective than sunlight it's gonna take
a long time he's only set a plug for me
this in fact but at least if you're not
if you're not suing and most of you
can't sue and most of you shouldn't sue
but you know what we want to live I love
how they shut off the lights yeah yeah
in there that's me was just so it was so
emblematic of the low yeah
I really didn't see the light until he
was a man so yeah that's what you can do
not everyone good look I really I don't
want to be the guy who's well and you
know where I seen this I I think that it
makes a lot of sense because you're it's
the same stuff that we're always
fighting for on the show you're fighting
for people that don't have a voice like
you do right who wouldn't be able to do
anything about it you're also fighting
to make sure that our universities can
change a little bit they won't change
unless pressure is put on them to change
and there's something I'd ask him well
there's definitely some important
considerations about whether it's
appropriate to do it but I think for
sure the thing that's not a
consideration and before you even get to
thinking about what happens with louder
with Crowder where you with you Stephen
individually is the university the
university has policies these policies
expressly place restrictions on what
professors can or can't do because those
are the same restrictions on students so
students wouldn't be able to get away
with standing up and accusing Charles
Hermes or one of the professor's or one
of the administrators of committing
crimes or those types of things right
and yet they want to say that even
though the policies are the same the
application should be different because
this is a professor so again student you
can't do this but a professor can and
those types of dichotomies are I think
at the heart of so much of the
frustration so our very first defense
should be institutions that at the very
least apply their own policies fairly
when people are clearly in the wrong
like right professor is exactly my point
as far as what this program is I would
only do something if I thought it set a
precedent where students would feel more
capable in expressing themselves where
students wouldn't have to live in fear
because listen what we do live shows and
we have a show I think it's a October
25th at U of M the students we met when
we talked about people being other no
one is other more than conservatives on
campus right now not the transgenders
not the LGBTQ a IP in a silent number-2
community not my no one is other more on
campus than concerned you see it with
this professor you see with him actually
actively protesting students and
screaming that they're fascist you see
it after we've released this video the
guy continues to lie only if there's
some kind of a precedent that does free
up students otherwise I think our time
energy best served on the show final
question how does it apply to the school
when they when they like you said they
support a guy like this and he doubles
down and says I got in trouble only me
early for telling the truth about steven
crowder yes that I'm a neo-nazi and
threatened to kill his son and the
school says no okay there's there's no
crime committed here this professors
still on staff was there any liability
there well there's you're gonna have
students who are paying tuition or their
parents whoever you know the students
probably the one though that has the
standing to take some action to say that
you're not applying the policies
correctly that there's a policy against
students accusing people of false crimes
and that policy applies this teachers
but we're not applying that here and
when a professor is using their platform
to do those types of things universities
absolutely have the right to step in in
certain instances again there's tenure
there's academic freedom but there is
certainly a boundary as with the First
Amendment to what these professors can
do and when they're using it in this way
that's when universe is absolutely can
so the students who are the ones who are
paying and who are harmed when this is
allowed to continue so at the very first
level there's that issue the other issue
is if they're condoning it if they're in
there and they're standing in there and
saying rah rah go do it we want you to
keep doing it we absolutely have your
back when you want to falsely accuse
people of crimes by the way just talking
about that he's actually he's a lecturer
which I found out from read one of our
brilliant researchers lecturer means
more of a contractor so he's not even
he's not a professor so the only the
only slander we committed was actually
upgrading him lecture so that point even
more so it'd be an easy break if they
wanted you there's a content it more
likely than not it's it's a different
situation where they have even more
rights to be able to enforce their
policies the way they should and that
undoubtedly these students feel should
be applied by the way I have a criminal
trespassing warrant warning at UT it
just means that I can't go back there
for a year without permission so put it
in my file the video where I would tell
you if you like this video to subscribe
only that doesn't mean anything anymore
because it doesn't necessarily appear in
your subscription feed so this is about
the point where you know I would tell
you to hit the notification bell but
that doesn't mean anything anymore
because he hid it nothing happened so
the only option you have is to join mug
club a lot of credit calm slash mug club
that way we don't lose contact with you
or at least bookmark this YouTube page
but I'm pretty sure that Google will
find a way to screw with your bookmarks
and switch it to Samantha B and CNN so
just join mug club unless you want us to
go away and of course all the
Bangladeshi children who will
as a result because they helped us with
developing costs